[Musik]
was hast Du denn gemacht in Minecraft
hast oh mein Gott wegen de Skin weil du
so halb Nack bist Minecraft oh mein Gott
du musst dein Skin
ern ich
schreibtereib weiter hier ab Schärfe
Haltbarkeit und noch ein
schleimball
Sandra
ja ich bin
gebannt nein hier steht dass dein Bann
jetzt auf mich rüber geschoben wurd dann
kannst du jetzt auf den Server drauf
gehen versuch mal versuch du mal auf den
Server draufzugehen okay warte Lua was
soll ich schreiben schreibt den
irgendwie sowas in die Richtung hey tut
mir leid also halt auf englisch ich habe
geschrieben sorry from
us das
[Musik]
gut wie bitte also ich habe eine 100000
€ Strafe 000 ist halt krass das kann ich
nicht machen Sandra schreib den mal ob
man sich nicht irgendwie anders einigen
kann ja aber dann dann dann schreib
[Musik]
mal
in in one hour liveestaming on Twitch
blaa irgendwie so keine Ahnung das ist
ja wirklich Arsch der Heide wir haben
halt wirklich scheiße jetzt gerade in
der Hose ne haben sie geantwortet Sandy
nee noch nicht e ich will auf dem Server
okay concraft been B say Sandra warning
been removed okay dann dann schreibt den
mal deine Mailadresse dass sie dir darin
dann dahin dann einfach schreiben sollen
wenn sie ein Ergebnis haben okay mal
deine
rein re so ich habe meine Mail jetzt
reingeschickt Laa das ist meine private
bist du dumm was schickst du die
rein
laserlaca das ist deine private Mail ja
ich fick dich durch dein
Arschloch Mist mir hat jemand gerade
Nachricht geschrieben hey Sandy über
Nachrichten so har reinges FI dich ich
fick dich durch de Arschloch
öffentliche Mail du hast wirklich mein
Leben gerade zerstört Sandra ich das ist
eine Mailadresse das ist jetzt nicht
deine Nummer ich ich bin gerade komplett
überfordert du darfst im Gegenzug darfst
du auch ein irgendwie eine Sache von mir
liegen oder so wenn Du möchtest nein so
bin ich nicht so bin ich nicht jetzt tut
die so als ob ich es extra gemacht hätte
e ich kann es jetzt nicht ändern wie
gesagt ich dachte das wäre deine deine
deine Dings se öffentliche Mail nein
hört auf mir E-Mails oh mein Gott mein
e-mailfaches komm
50 € gekostet danke aber junge ich bin
aber ich meine wenigstens haben wir die
ganze Sache mit Minecraft
geklärt lie
geblieben len das nicht auf die tötet
mich nur wenige Minuten später warum
schreibt mir alle D michprankt hast
war das prank nein wie denn ich wurde
doch auch gebannt okay
gut leute bitte hört auf Chat zu Spam
ich soll den prank auflösen ich werde
das noch machen aber ich muss mir gerade
überlegen wie ich das irgendwie Sandra
vernünftig beibringe sie muss jetzt
erstmal bessere Laune kriegen ist
richtig m dass Ihre Mailadresse Aussehen
von mir geliegt wurde deswegen ich muss
jetzt erstmal abwarten bis sie
vielleicht bisschen bessere Laun also
wir lassen das them beiseite und kümmern
uns jetzt hierum hast du schon mal
türkische Gerichte gegessen natürlich
liebe türkisches Essen das ist glaube
ich neben der italienischen Küche die
die ich am meisten mag
ja also wer uns nach diesem Stream hier
heute bei Twitch folgt der kann
direktfolgen der ist nicht mehr zu
retten auch wenn das kostenlos ist zu
folgen also wirklich das ist das Dümmste
was ich jemals in einem Twitch
Livestream gesehen habe was hier heute
passier das
[Musik]
kannst ich sage noch heute geht alles
schief wie kannüberhaupt und in dem
Moment springt die Kröte einfach in den
Abgrund was bei ihm kaputter können
keine Zombies spawnen wenn ich auf dem
Block drauf
stehe oh mein Gott s hier spawt einfach
nichts mehr ich glaube ich habe ein
lifehack gefunden doch
nicht wieso bin ich denn jetzt oh mein
Gott sy ist auf dem guten Weg wieder
gute Laune zu kriegen K am Ende sagen
damit die Laune jetzt gerade wieder hoch
geht um dann wieder an Boden zu fallen
wo Sandy Skin Sandy musste ihren Skin
ändern weil wir sie geprankt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
haben sie ist aus dem K rausgegangen und
er dropt es einfach so in einem
Nebensatz er hat sich selber verr
oh mein Gott ich habe nicht selber
verraten sie hört mich gerade nicht
nicht selber verraten ich war ein guter
Zeitpunkt das mal kurz droen sie war
endlich wieder gut
drauf la wieder Keller
kleiner ja okay Handy jetzt komplett
raus hier aus dem Call noch mal ganz
kurz an alle zusammengefasst ich habe
mit dem Server Ersteller von unserer Map
hier einen prank an Sandra gemacht wir
haben nämlich Fake Nachrichten im Chat
geschrieben wir habenle aber wir haben
Fake Nachrichten reingeschrieben als
würden die Nachrichten von MO also
Studio hinter Minecraft geschickt worden
sein und dann stand da sowas drin wie oh
warte Sandra ruft an ja Sandy was los
sag jetzt noch mal laut ich habe schon
laut gesagt also der serverersteller hat
dich geprankt und ich habe mitgespielt
es ist alles nur passiert weil prank war
also der prank war das wird so tun als
ob dein Skin nicht geeignet wäre unser B
noch
dran
hallo aufgelegt boah ich weiß gerade
nicht ob die wirklich sauer ist oder
nicht also ich kann es natürlich
verstehen aber es ist jetzt jetzt nicht
die Welt untergegangen oderer
Sandy erklär mir das und sag die
komplette Wahrheit also ich habe es
gerade schon im Stream gesagt der Server
hier wurde von einem Mod von meinem
discord Server gemacht und der hat diese
Map hier erstellt und hat einfach in den
Chat reingeschrieben so eine Nachricht
auf Englisch als wäre er das moang also
moang ist das entwicklerbu hinter
Minecraft die haben das entwickelt so
der hat dann auf jeden Fall diese
Nachrichten in den Chat geschrieben und
hat dir dann so geschrieben darauf hatte
ich auch gar keinen Einfluss deswegen
habe ich auch da die ganze Zeit gesagt
das ist ich ich ich prank dich gerade
nicht so nach Motto ne du wusstest aber
dass es dein Mod ist das wusste ich das
stimmt aber ich habe dich nicht geprankt
ich habe quasi mitgemacht du versuchst
dich da so
rauszureden junge Junge was bist du für
ein falscher Profi Alter so oder so also
warte lass mich ausreden so versucht er
sich so nee Luca ich brauche da jetzt
auch gar keine Meinung mehr zu in
Ordnung ich brauch da gar keine Meinung
zu ne allein schon der
asekt dass du es wusstest lass mich doch
Ausreden lass mir dir doch das nein nein
das brauch ich nicht oh mann es tut mir
leid das war nicht extra wir sehen uns
hören uns wenn ihr beim nächsten Stream
dabei sein wollt
wir gehen ja manchmal auch einfach so
spontan live wie z.B gestern dann folgt
einfach hier auf Twitch ist komplett
kostenlos haut rein ich habe euch
[Musik]
lieb